Transcription: Amira Shehab
Relecteur: Anne-Sophie Matichard
« Quel courage !
Moi, je ne pourrai pas. »
C’est ce que l’on me dit lorsque
j’explique ce que je fais dans la vie,
et c’est aussi ce qu’entendent
les personnes dont je m’occupe.
Moi, je suis coach,
coach de survie,
et mes coachés sont
des patients atteints de cancer.
Avant, j’étais soignante.
Quand vous êtes soignant,
il n’a pas marqué docteur sur la blouse
et vous ne faites pas non plus
partie de la famille.
Vous êtes un humain en pyjama,
disponible pour écouter les vécus
et les ressentis des personnes.
Et j’ai été cette oreille attentive
et je continue à l’être aujourd’hui.
Lorsque mon entourage a su que
j’allais travailler en oncologie,
ils m’ont dit : « Mais tu ne vas
travailler qu’avec des personnes âgées. »
Sauf que ma cochée, la plus jeune,
a 14 ans,
et que la moyenne est autour de 35 ans.
Le cancer ne choisit pas l’âge,
c’est quelque chose qui s’invite à table
alors que personne ne l’a invité.
C’est quelque chose avec lequel
on doit composer jour et nuit,
pendant plusieurs semaines
à toute une vie.
Quand vous avez un cancer,
on vous l’annonce.
C’est un moment un peu particulier
qu’on appelle le choc de l’annonce.
C’est à partir de ce moment-là
qu’on parle d’après cancer.
Et lorsqu’on vous l’a annoncé,
vous êtes littéralement
dessaisi de votre agenda,
on vous demande de faire des examens,
des prises de sang, des biopsies,
des scanners, des IRM,
des radios, des scintigraphies,
de la radiothérapie, une chimiothérapie,
de la cryothérapie.
Bref, tout ce qu’il faut pour survivre.
On ne choisit pas d’avoir le cancer.
On le subit.
C’est pour cette raison que mes coachés,
lorsque la voisine leur dit :
« Ha, vous avez un cancer,
mais quel courage !
Moi, je pourrai pas. »
Mes coachés, ils ont plutôt envie de
lui faire une clé de bras, à la voisine.
Que font les gens concrètement avec moi ?
Eh bien, ils travaillent leur capacité
à se projeter dans l’avenir.
Il y a un parcours spécialisé,
vous vous en doutez,
et au départ...
une évaluation avec une échelle,
une échelle qui ressemble à l’EVA.
Pour ceux qui ne savent pas
ce qu’est l’EVA,
c’est une réglette grande comme ça,
graduée de 1 à 10,
pour évaluer la douleur des patients.
À un, vous avez une douleur
qui est très légère,
et à dix, vous avez une douleur
qui est insoutenable.
La mienne s'appelle l'EFA.
L’échelle de futurisation analogique.
À un, vous êtes à l’arrêt,
vous ne savez pas du tout
comment organiser votre avenir,
et à dix, c’est fluide,
vous savez comment vous y prendre
et vous connaissez toutes les étapes.
Quand j’évalue mes patients,
je me rends compte -
j’évalue, je fais des statistiques -
et ce qui saute aux yeux, c’est 4,3.
43 % de capacité à se projeter
dans l’avenir.
C’est moins de la moyenne,
et c’est tout âge confondu.
Après trois mois d’accompagnement,
on arrive pour les plus de 50 ans à 80%,
pour les moins de 35 ans à 83%
et pour les 35/50 ans à 86%
de capacité à se projeter dans l’avenir.
Mon objectif est qu’à la fin du parcours,
les patients soient en capacité
d’avoir la sensation
d’avoir les rênes de leur vie
entre leurs mains.
Puisque pour moi, le courage,
c’est le moment où le patient a choisi
de traverser le cancer à sa manière.
Alors tout se passait bien
jusqu’au moment où la Covid est arrivée,
et à ce moment-là,
des personnes qui n’avaient pas de cancer,
pas de maladie chronique,
pas même la Covid,
sont venues se présenter à moi.
D’abord, il y a eu les gens
de l’hôtellerie,
puis ceux de la restauration,
ceux du social
et enfin les consultants,
les banquiers et d’autres.
Ces personnes sont venues me demander
de les accompagner,
sauf qu’entre l’école à la maison
et mon activité habituelle,
je n’avais pas le temps de leur proposer
quelque chose de vraiment spécifique.
À priori ce n’était pas grave, ils avaient
vraiment un besoin qui était urgent.
Donc je leur ai expliqué qu’ils pouvaient,
s’ils le voulaient,
suivre le même parcours
que ceux de mes patients.
Et c’est ce qui a été fait.
J’ai procédé à la même évaluation,
avec mon échelle, l’EFA,
que pour mes patients.
Et là , je me suis rendue compte
qu’ils étaient à 4,3,
moins de la moyenne,
tout âge confondu.
C’est à ce moment-là que j’ai compris
l’impact que la crise allait avoir
sur la santé mentale des gens.
Aujourd’hui si je vous parle de ça,
c’est pour vous rassurer.
Les gens dont je m’occupe en général ont
leur vie personnelle ou professionnelle
qui a littéralement volé en éclats.
Et pourtant, elles sont toujours là.
Et aujourd’hui, je voudrais vous partager
des astuces et des histoires
pour vous aider à traverser l’adversité.
Je voudrais commencer par les gangs.
Pour moi, il y a trois types de personnes,
répartis en trois gangs bien distincts.
Alors peut-être que vous faites partie
des « Pourquoi moi ? ».
Les « Pourquoi moi ? » sont les personnes
qui disent « Jamais deux sans trois »,
ou « Le sort s’acharne ».
Ce sont des gens qui s’attendent parfois
à ce que le malheur arrive.
Sinon, il y a les « Oui mais ».
Pour les « Oui, mais »
il y a deux catégories.
Ceux qui se trouvent des excuses :
« Oui mais t’as vu le temps qui fait ? »
« Oui mais tu sais, on a les enfants,
on ne peut pas. »
« Oui, mais j’ai piscine. »
et ceux-là n’ont jamais eu l’intention
de faire quoi que ce soit.
Il y a les autres « Oui mais »,
ceux qui tentent des choses :
« Oui mais combien de temps
ça va me prendre ?
Et combien d’argent ça va me coûter ? »
« Oui mais que vont dire les autres ? »
Ceux-là se débattent avec des possibilités
et on salue l’effort.
Le dernier groupe est celui
des « Comment »,
et quand on ferme la porte
au nez d’un « Comment »,
en général, ils trouvent une solution
pour rentrer par la fenêtre.
Ils trouvent la capacité de sortir
de la plainte pour faire réagir.
Ce soir, je voudrais vous donner
des formules pour passer de l’un à l’autre
si vous êtes coincé dans un gang.
Pour passer des « Pourquoi moi ? »
au « Oui mais »,
il y a le « Et si je »,
à ne pas confondre
avec le « Et si » qui refait le monde.
Pour passer du « Oui mais »
au « comment », il y en a plusieurs.
Il y a le « On va trouver une solution ».
Il y a le « On va s’adapter ».
Il y a le « Rha j’en ai envie
quand même ».
Et il y a le « Pfff, et puis zut ! »,
et on y va.
Ce qui m’intéresse,
c’est que vous vous soyez identifié
et qu’à partir de là,
on puisse vous donner un peu
de projection dans l’avenir.
Et pour cela, on va utiliser une courbe,
celle d’Elisabeth Kübler Ross,
qui ressemble un peu à un creux de vague
et qui a plusieurs étapes.
Je vais tenter de vous les illustrer
avec des ressentis
que mes patients pourraient avoir.
En premier, vous avez le choc :
« Mais on est en train de me dire
que j’ai un cancer là. »
Ensuite, vous avez le déni :
« Il a dit tumeur,
il n’a pas dit cancer ».
Ensuite vous avez la colère :
« Bon sang, je paye mes impôts,
je suis sympa avec tout le monde,
je mange bien, je fais du sport,
pourquoi moi ? »
Ensuite, vous avez la négociation :
« Je vais aller consulter ailleurs,
dans un autre hôpital. »
Et enfin, vous avez la dépression.
Pour remonter la vague, vous allez pouvoir
expérimenter de nouvelles choses,
les intégrer à votre quotidien
et vous arriverez à sortir de la vague.
Si vous arrivez à vous projeter en point
de départ quelque part sur cette courbe,
alors vous aurez la perspective
de ce qu’il vous reste à dérouler
et vous arriverez à vous sortir
de n’importe quelle situation.
Et j’ajoute que si vous arrivez
à trouver en chemin
ce que vous a apporté l’expérience,
alors vous toucherez du doigt
ce que l’on appelle la résilience.
J’ai trois histoires pour vous ce soir,
dont celle de Marc.
Alors Marc, c’est un homme de 40 ans
et qui a un cancer de mauvais pronostic.
Et Marc est atterré,
il est vraiment vraiment très très mal.
Mais ce n’est pas à cause de son cancer
qu’il est très mal.
Le matin même de la consultation,
il a enterré son père,
qui est mort avant lui
d’une crise cardiaque.
Il ne s’y attendait pas
et durant l’oraison funèbre,
il n’a pas réussi à retrouver
le sport de jeunesse de son père.
Ma première leçon
concerne l’environnement :
je vous invite à créer, choisir,
honorer votre environnement,
qu’il soit végétal, animal,
matériel ou humain.
Et s’il s’agit de l’humain,
je vous invite à vraiment vous demander
s’il est adapté à votre personne.
Ensuite, nous avons Caroline.
Caroline, c’est une dame
à qui l’on a annoncé la rémission,
et Caroline se débat
avec un sentiment de culpabilité.
Elle m’explique que durant ses traitements
qui ont été très longs,
son mari a été présent partout.
Il a pris des jours de congé pour l’amener
en consultation, pour ses traitements.
Il a fait le taxi pour sa radiothérapie -
c’est tous les jours la radiothérapie.
Il s’est occupé de leurs trois enfants,
fait l’intendance à la maison,
il a été juste exceptionnel.
Sauf que Caroline, son mari...
Elle ne l’aime plus.
Et elle m’explique que ça fait un moment
qu’elle le sait,
et qu’il lui a fallu un cancer
pour qu’elle se l’avoue.
Alors le cancer,
c’est un parcours très particulier
qui sélectionne ceux qui restent
malgré tout.
Et c’est un parcours qui permet
de gagner en authenticité.
L’authenticité, je trouve ça très bien :
ça me permet de discuter avec des gens
qui sont sans voile mensonger,
qui sont vraiment bruts,
comme des diamants bruts.
Le problème dans l’authenticité,
c’est le curseur.
Quand le curseur va trop loin,
vous avez en face de vous des gens
qui sont trop rigides, trop catégoriques.
Et l’antidote à cela,
c’est l’enchantement.
Et l’enchantement,
Lolita l’a bien compris.
Lolita, elle a 21 ans,
elle est en dernière année
d’école de commerce,
et on vient aussi de lui annoncer
la rémission.
Et Lolita n’a qu’une seule envie,
c’est de faire le tour du monde, seule,
peu importe si elle ne finit pas
ses études,
peu importe si elle n’a pas son diplôme,
peu importe si ses parents
ne sont pas contents.
Tout ce qu’elle veut, Lolita,
c’est récupérer le temps qu’on lui a volé,
c’est réenchanter son quotidien.
Alors si vous voulez vous aussi
réenchanter votre quotidien,
vous pouvez vous refixer sur votre corps,
sur vos sensations, sur vos cinq sens.
Vous pouvez aussi réintégrer du rire,
des pastels, de la couleur.
Vous pouvez aller au théâtre, au cinéma,
voir des arts ;
ces choses qui sont non essentielles
et pourtant si essentielles
à l’enchantement de la vie.
J’ajouterai à cela qu’il faut travailler
votre capacité à être en mouvement,
à faire du lien et à être déconnecté.
Je terminerai avec ceci :
« Si ça n’existe pas,
je vais l’inventer ».
C’est la phrase que j’ai dite à mon patron
lorsque j’ai donné ma lettre de démission.
J’adorais mon métier et pourtant,
j’ai souhaité le quitter.
Je vous invite ce soir à construire
votre avenir, à l’incarner
pour qu’il soit conforme
à ce que vous voulez.
Parce que le courage,
ce n’est pas de subir,
mais de traverser et de bâtir.
Nous sommes tous des survivants.
Et puisque la fin est inéluctable,
n’attendez donc pas un drame de vie
pour avoir le courage d’être vous-même.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)